so this is absolute and total gold uh
we've been talking about
how will republicans defend or not
defend
radical congresswoman marjorie taylor
greene's
various comments including about a
jewish space laser starting wildfires
when she harassed teen activist david
hogg on the streets of washington dc
when she encouraged violence and even
posted to facebook
about the murder of democrats denying
911
denying sandy hook and so on and so
forth and so far we saw
on yesterday's show we saw republican
congressman steve scalise
turn the question into an answer about
joe biden china and carbon so that's one
approach which is
just don't even answer the question
answer about something else attack joe
biden
we saw on yesterday's show republican
congresswoman nancy mace
did do a both sides thing which was to
say okay well
both sides have crazy people in them so
that's sort of like a what about ism
both sides type response trump brown
noser and republican senator
lindsey graham is taking a third
approach
which is to say that the comments might
have been taken out of context
he barely seems able to even get the
names right of the various conspiracies
touted by marjorie taylor green but he
says what about context
take a look at this that you have spent
some time with her
where do you come down on this idea
whether she should be stripped of
committee assignments
well rather than me talking about what
she may have said i want to hear from
her
so i flew down to georgia with her on
air force one had a very pleasant
experience with her very very cordial
very pleasant
so here's what i think she owes herself
quite frankly her
constituents in the country is that true
was she misquoted was she taken out of
context i want to know does she still
believe that
sandy hooks was faked that 911 was an
inside job that
there's a jewish laser laser in the sky
starting
fires in california i don't know i know
how words can be twisted i know how you
can be
taken out of context but rather than me
talking about her
i would like her to be definitive i
seriously love that
does she really think a jewish space
laser or laser
as lindsay says is starting wildfires
because you know her comments about a
jewish space laser
might lack some context within which
they'd be reasonable comments to make
we need the full context of when she
talked about a jewish space laser
what can you imagine that being the
defense
the only context that would be relevant
about what marjorie taylor greene
said about a jewish space laser would be
if she had said
what i am about to say is a joke right
before saying it
short of that what sort of context would
make a comment
like that about jewish space lasers even
remotely reasonable
and in terms of context much of this
stuff was on a post on
facebook that's the context the post is
the context and this is just another
form of republican gaslighting now
think of some other examples is there a
context that makes the statement
the moon landing was faked reasonable
i guess the context would be i'm about
to say something that's a joke like i
can't think of another context that
would make the statement
the moon landing was faked reasonable
vaccines
autism might be a totally reasonable
thing
if we had the context only yeah but the
only context would be
i'm about to say something that is
untrue maybe when she stalked
teen activist david hogg and it was
caught on video
maybe there was missing context there as
well i don't know
and while we're at it maybe there's
context that makes lindsey graham's
comment
less ridiculous although i can't really
think of what it would be now here's a
serious question
is it possible that republicans
like lindsay and others don't know what
context means
so when they say this was taken out of
context
they actually don't understand the
meaning of that is that a possibility i
mean we've had a lot of times where
we'll be engaged in you know a week's
long or month-long discussion
uh with the discussion maybe is a bit of
a favorable term but
a disagreement with the right about
something and
after two months you'll realize oh my
goodness they don't even know what this
word means we're arguing about something
assuming both sides understand the
meaning of the words we're using and
this entire time they're they're
using a word that they don't even
understand or they misunderstand
maybe lindsey graham doesn't know what
context means but in any case it's sort
of like a pick your own adventure
either marjorie taylor green misspoke or
it was posted by a staffer
not really marjorie taylor green or
maybe the video was deep
faked or maybe it was taken out of
context
or she was telling a joke or she was on
a medication at that point in time like
just pick one whichever one makes you
feel better about what she said
pick your own adventure and go with it
and so far
three different uh responses to marjorie
taylor green's comments
let's now talk about the fourth response